is a distinguished professor of history
at American University and author of the
case for impeachment Allan Lichtman
Allan
[Applause]
how are you I'm doing great to see you
okay well impeachment is certainly on a
lot of people's minds that's what your
book is about we're gonna talk about
that later but for now I just want to
say you have unique credibility when it
comes to talking about what's going to
happen because back was it in 1981 okay
you came out with this prediction model
for elections 13 keys that could tell us
who's gonna win you got it right every
time
except mm why'd you [ __ ] up that year I
didn't get it Laura did that's right a
stolen election right I wrote the report
Service Commission on civil rights that
proved it interesting they threw out one
out of nine of every ballot cast by an
african-american right head to one out
of 54 ballots cast right by whites
african-americans 95 percent Democratic
gore should have won going away okay so
[Music]
all right Jeb Bush got along all right
so the 13 Keys we're talking about I
mean some of them are very obvious like
incumbency if the president is an
incumbent right if there's a significant
third party candidate if there's a
recession going on and then there's one
scandal if the current administration is
undergoing a scandal you say this is why
we have to have impeachment hearings but
aren't they already checking the box for
scandal the problem is you can't do it
through scattered investigations in six
or seven different committees right that
plays right into the hands of a
president who you know is a master of
distraction and deflection to nail it
you've got to have the formality and
constitutional power and focus of an
impeachment process you know Nancy
Pelosi has said this president is such a
criminal that he should be in jail well
frankly it's congressional malpractice
then not to invoke the proper
conversational rubber
okay but okay okay hey that will always
get applause in Los Angeles that's
pretty well it's a turn about applause
now that's right we're talking about how
to win that's correct okay so that's the
question they're used you're saying and
I'm not disagreeing with you that if
impeachment hearings will put scandal on
the map as far as one of those keys and
that you say the Democrats there's 13
keys they need six six negative against
Donald Kent and they have now three only
three what do they have what are the
three they have a midterm elections the
latter elections are the party out of
power won the race terms okay that's one
key no big splashy foreign policy
success right and the fact that Trump
only about him loves him yeah right yeah
that the biggest negative you could
imagine right nothing okay and and the
fact that he only appeals to a narrow
base he's not like Ronald Reagan a
charismatic and that it with broad
appeal that's three impeachment would be
he's not a charismatic and he is not
doesn't have rotted it up right in his
Bayes not a race he's just in his base
all right impeachment is four that gives
him only a two key cushion and it could
trigger other Keys like like if he gets
beaten up which I think he would if
there was a real impeachment process or
it could trigger a contest for his
nomination or a third part or maybe the
Democrats will grow a backbone and
you'll see a charismatic candidate
emerge so you know so you say Karras
as Matic candidate is one of the keys I
don't see anybody on their side who has
it was a charismatic candidate bill I
never prejudge if there's one word I
want to eliminate from the political
lexicon it is electability because you
do not know it I totally whose Matic I'm
just saying yeah if it's that carriage
man you don't know yet you know for duck
hey I'm Ryan you know we make this point
for decades and we love you the
Democrats have believed that the way to
win elections is to pick someone from
the center line and establishment
candidate just like Hillary Clinton Al
Gore and John Kerry and what do they all
have in common
they've all are lost Democrats you need
what was we think what you're doing was
in Bill Clinton the centrist but he was
off the wall he was out of the
mainstream he was hardly an
establishment Democrat neither was Jimmy
Carter he was he was a governor of his
southern state but who ever heard of him
he was on What's My Line the great
program and no one knew who he was
okay but no but as a centrist can win in
many centuries he'll I'm not saying you
can't be a centrist so you got to be
exciting ya got to inspire people that's
what counts
I'm with the with the mob you're welcome
I want I want the winner I don't care if
it's a centrist or the leftist I'm a
little more left but I'm for the winner
okay so let me ask you this yes what
about keys maybe you haven't identified
a lot has happened since 1981 what about
a negative key which would I
I would guess would be infighting in the
party out of power
there's a lot of that going on now with
the Democrats I was that a key and
negative key even though I've studied
that carefully and infighting only
counts for the party holding the White
House because it is a commentary on
governance and running the country and
the out party can fight all at once look
at the Republicans in 2016 so like the
the Hillary Bernie fights had no effect
no that is they were in power they were
the empowered Democrat but the Hillary
Obama when they were challengers had no
effect so fight away Democrats don't
worry about I don't you
let's have a great debate well I don't
know I don't know because I think again
your model I think there's some things
that are going on now that weren't
around like foreign influence that's not
a key it's Fox News that's new from 1981
two great questions one foreign
influence it can't be a key because you
don't know in advance
who's gonna meddle how successful
they'll be and on whose behalf they're
going to meddle but if the Russians come
back again and I think Bill Trump will
welcome them again and if this time they
get into our voting machines that would
not just destroy the keys that would in
fact destroy our democracy that's why
we've got to desperately do something to
counter this kind of foreign meddling
that sadly so that isn't is welcoming
it's not a key but I'm saying it could
destroy the keys but that's a minor
problem because we would destroy our
country I'm gonna call that a key okay
well our kid what about Fox News I mean
look when you I saw this woman
interviewed outside of his rally this
week and what do you like about him she
said he doesn't lie okay that's that's
kind of a key when like 40% of the
country watches this channel that never
reports anything banned that he does you
know bill we've had highly partisan
media back from the days of George
Washington you look at some of the media
than some of the newspapers they got not
in our lifetime on his man like fart I
think Fox News shot something this is a
nice TV this way you never had state TV
Island well we've had state media
newspapers but there's a deeper point
here which is illustrated by Fox News we
have an America today two parties we
have a Republican Party with no
principles but a spine and we have a
Democratic Party with principles but no
spine the Democrats have a chance to get
courage out
last word
[Applause]
you